thank you it's my pleasure to introduce
my colleague Pamela Hyde whom I will
call Pam Pam and I have worked together
for nearly 20 years she is also a
co-director of the Center for work
technology and organization and as a
member of the department of management
science and engineering she received her
PhD in organization science and
management Carnegie Mellon University
Pam is without doubt both nationally and
internationally acclaimed as a pas
expert in the field of distributed work
and distributed teams she's been
studying this for nearly 20 years her
2000 look her book that she published in
2000 called distributed work has become
a classic she has moved over her career
from various topics about distributed
work I think you're going to find her
insights to be provocative and with that
let me start with the first question why
do we even use distributed teams Pam I
mean in this just creating problems for
self well they're variety of reasons
why organizations are using a lot of
distributed and global teams it's been
interesting to watch over the last
couple of decades and and how the
rhetoric and the motivation for this has
changed then this initially when I was
talking with executives it was really
all about saving costs all right and if
you can go to India or you can go to
China then you can get local low-cost
labor and really bring your costs down
but since that time I think the it's
gotten more sophisticated you know the
reasons that organizations are doing
this are sophisticated in some ways I
think more compelling one of those is
getting access to
Garrus expertise you know it's just that
you know particularly in technical
fields been in a variety of fields if
you really want the world's best they're
not located in one place and oftentimes
people aren't willing to move in order
to take the job that you're offering
them so it necessitates working in this
more global manner and then the other is
that you know the markets are
increasingly global and that means that
you know if you want to tap in to say
the market in China it's really
important to have a presence in China
and to understand that context and to be
able to localize your products or
services for that environment so it
becomes really crucial for a lot of
organizations to be global in order to
to serve the markets that they want to
serve now it does make it more difficult
you know the reality is that global
teams where distributed teams are harder
to manage they tend to be slower not
faster they tend to be more expensive
not less expensive despite the reduced
cost of labor because you've got a whole
variety of other costs that come into
play and they can be really taxing for
the individuals and the leaders that are
working on these teams because people
are having to travel they're having to
stay up until you know midnight in order
to participate on conference calls with
people on the other side the world and
so forth but one of things that's
interesting some recent research that
we've done seems to suggest that
comparing domestic teams with global
teams people who are working on global
teams are actually oftentimes more
engaged they feel like they're learning
more so there's also a challenge to
doing it it may be positive I find that
hard to believe
all right I find it hard to believe
because I know in my own life being able
to meet people that I'm working with is
really important right and so how do you
how do you do
with the fact that many people are these
teams are never gonna see each other
face to face isn't that it's not a
problem yeah I mean I would actually
question the assumption that they aren't
going to see each other most of the time
so a lot of the teams that I studied
their long-term interdependent kinds of
teams and and I think most organizations
have gotten to the point where they
understand that people do need to meet
the face and I would I would even go
further and differentiate face to face
from site visits the face to face is
great you know it's an opportunity to
you know maybe learn about the
communication styles of another person
to get a sense of their personality
sense of humor and so forth which is
great but site visits where you're
actually going and spending time in the
person's work location you know for
three days seven days whatever it is
maybe a longer period of time that's
where I think it really matters because
people are then able to see how people
work what their work context is life but
what it's like what their behavior is
like and what constrains their behavior
within the cultural context in which
they're working and they're their family
context they get a much better sense of
how the person is viewed within that
local social network and that actually
matters a lot you know do people
continually go to that person for advice
or is it somebody that is marginalized
within that local social so if you tell
us a story about how fight business
changed the perception of of you know
team members notions of who it was they
were interacting with yeah no absolutely
and and I would say the things that we
definitely see in our research is that
the collaboration and nature of the
collaboration that people have
fundamentally changes after site visits
also well they they you know I kind of
think of it the analogy is walking
around
a pitch-dark room right when you're
walking around a pitch-dark room through
a maze you're kind of slow going
tentative you look at the walls break
through those walls and you'd go slow so
that you don't right so people do that
with less confidence they're not really
sure of what it is they're seeing they
don't know how to interpret it and
that's kind of the way it is when people
haven't met somebody or seen the context
that they're working in is there they're
tentative they don't know when it's okay
to contact somebody they don't know if
it's okay to call them on their cell
phone even even the person is said it's
okay until they see that that person
really is on their cell phone talking
about work all the time they just don't
know within that cultural context
whether or not that's okay so it really
matter so let me tell you one story
where it really changed the nature of
the relationship there's a person in
India he had been working for about six
months with somebody in Germany and he
said you know it just it wasn't going
well it was clear that the guy in
Germany didn't like him and he just
didn't know why said you know the guy is
just just really abrupt with them and
yeah the relationship was just difficult
and and he felt like there was nothing
that he could do you know he worked so
hard to sort of build rapport with this
person in Germany and it just never
heard seem to get better so he said you
know I just started trying to avoid him
and and interact with less with him
because I just didn't know how to
improve the situation but then he said I
went to Germany and I saw this guy in
his natural content context so speak and
realized that he was much more harsh and
abrasive with the people in his local
environment and I realized that in fact
he was trying with me and that the
relationship that I had with him wasn't
bad there was nothing that I'd done it's
just how this guy is yeah and and you
know he realized that what he was doing
was making assumptions about the meaning
of this person's behavior without
being able to be accurate about those
assumptions so early on in this
conversation you said something very
interesting and that was that
turns out using distributed teams is
actually more expensive not less expand
then using co-located teams now you know
as you pointed out right one of the
major reasons for why people use these
and use distributed work right is to
lower their labor cost and I have a hard
time believing that's still not a
motivation right so I'd like to hear
more about why it's more costly to do
than to do face-to-face teams yeah well
I probably shouldn't have said it quite
so it's a blanket statement like that so
I think it can be less costly it depends
on you know the work that's being done
the number of people that you've got in
a low-cost low-cost labor area but if
you're really looking at interdependent
work where you've got people that really
have to work together in order to
deliver a product then there needs to be
enough interaction between them there
needs to be travel there needs to be
structures that enable people to work
together more effectively and those are
expensive so you know it may still be
that it's slightly less expensive to
have you know these global or
distributed teams if you're going to
low-cost labor markets but it's not as
cheap as one might think it is because
of all of these additional costs and one
of them is you know come out of pocket
costs for the cost of travel right if
you're gonna do it well the other is
like I said it takes longer and there's
it's really clear that it's just faster
to do for example development work with
everybody co-located okay thank you that
clarifies the situation for me so tell
me about the difference between you know
we have a whole bunch of words you're
talking about
right and one word is distributed work
any other word is global work right in
your mind do those things mean the same
thing yeah the way I would think about
it is that global work is a type of
distributed work so distributed work is
usually a term that refers to any time
that people are not co-located for
example on the same campus they might be
in a state might be in the state they
might be in the same state within the US
or even the one end of the spoke on
valley on the other they could be yeah
so so really what it refers to is the
the difficulties that they're going to
have getting together in order to meet
face to face
whereas global teams of course now
people are located in different
countries around the globe with all that
comes with that including more dramatic
cultural differences language
differences timezone is often a really
big factor in these things in these
teams right well then that leads me to
my next classic right if you've got
these globally distributed teams and
members of people who are people and
members around people and who have been
raised and socialized at different
cultures have different customs who have
Tirpitz things differently the same
thing differently right doesn't this
these cultural differences don't they
kind of mess things up they do make it
more challenging yeah so the and it
depends on how different the cultures
are but yeah oftentimes what happens is
you know when you're working in a
distributed manner people remain
embedded in these very different
cultural contexts and those cultural
contexts affect the way that people work
the way that people think about the
world they're in oftentimes a very
different political context an economic
context can be quite different the you
know even the seasons can be different
if you're going north to south and all
of this affects the way that people
behave and
what I see is that you know there's a
real attempt to align practices and a
real I would guess I would say a lack of
awareness of how important these
cultural contexts are in determining
what acceptable behaviors are and
meaning within that local context and
and that creates real challenges in
working across this context so what's
the most surprising case of this that
you've encountered Oh a surprising case
well one of the kind of a fun case is we
have been working with an organization
that is trying to create innovation
centers around the world so the end of
the initial Innovation Center idea was
kind of developed in the Silicon Valley
and the idea then was to spread it to
other parts of the world so in this
study we were looking very closely at
what was happening in India and in China
and the metaphor that this organization
was using was the garage metaphor they
really wanted sort of a really startup a
provisional unfinished kind of
environment because that Spurs
creativity here in this cultural context
what turned out that that just it not
only didn't mean innovation in these
other contract contexts it was seen as
going backward
you know the particularly in China is
like why would we want to go back to
sort of provisional cement floors things
being unfinished when you know we've
just sort of moved beyond that so that
metaphor just fell flat in in these
other places well that's pretty
interesting right so there's no point
like working in a place where you have
machine tools and this sort of stop
right yeah so now that foam so one of
the things that I think that I find
quite interesting is it so many global
companies
not just American companies global
companies from other countries have
declared that English is going to be the
lingua franca and I know that you've
paid some attention right to language
differences even when all right English
is the superimposed language that
everyone is supposed to talking so
doesn't just studying a lingua franca
have some help you overcome these
problems yeah I mean if you didn't have
a lingua franca you'd be in trouble
right right because you might be able to
communicate at all so there needs to be
a lingua franca and you know for a whole
variety of historical reasons it's sort
of evolved that English tends to be the
lingua franca for most of these
companies that are operating globally so
it does solve a lot of problems but it
also introduces some really interesting
problems because particularly if you're
looking at native versus non-native
English speakers so a large part of the
world may speak English fluently but
they're not native English speakers what
that means is that they may not have
access to as wide of a vocabulary they
may not be able to be as precise in
their use of the language they may have
more difficulty expressing emotions and
more difficult to articulate and they
may toward the end of the day when
they're tired have a harder time
producing English because it's
cognitively more challenging - for a lot
of people to speak in a non-native
language especially if they're not
living in an English language contacts
right um so what we see happens then is
especially when you've got native
English speakers interacting with
non-native English speakers is you have
a bit of a language dominance or power
thing going on especially when you've
got people from countries that have
communication norms
that are fairly assertive and you know
where we interrupt people a lot and we
talk a lot that would be like America
that would be like Americans for example
so then you can imagine in these
situations where you know the native
English speakers and the Americans who
aren't having to search for the word to
use end up dominating the conversation
and making it really difficult for the
non-native speakers to participate
actively we have that innate non-native
English speakers working with non-native
English speakers some of those problems
actually go away so it's actually better
when both of them are speaking to
something third language surprisingly is
what's the most what's the most I don't
want to say the word interesting that's
good what's the most provocative case of
this that you've seen pocket of case a
specific case right I'll talk just for a
minute about code-switching
that sure that's an interesting
dimension right choice so one of the
things that we see happens is you know
let's say that you know we're working
with a group from France
okay and it's our morning at the end of
their day we're of course the native
English speakers they are fluent but not
necessarily native speakers of English
what may end up happening what
frequently happens in that context is
that they'll switch to French for part
of the conversation so that they can
alleviate some of the cognitive load and
also be more articulate and precise in
their ability to talk about whatever it
is they were talking about and then
maybe at the end of that they might give
some kind of a summary but with that and
you know that's there's a perfectly
reasonable thing to do probably
inappropriate but as the non French
speakers the anglo-saxon guys right yeah
yeah well and it's not it's actually not
just the anglo-saxon side it
to beeban on the speakers of whatever
language it is ha that they switched to
so even people who are not monolingual
tend to get a little bit rustled about
this Americans are particularly
sensitive to it
but then you know people feel left out
of the conversation they feel devalued
they wonder why they're even spending
their time in this meeting are they
really talking about me and I don't know
you know our lingua Franca's English why
aren't they speaking English this is not
right so you end up with a lot of
tensions around that well I know that
there's a lot of folks out there we just
love to have a list of the best
practices that they could implement or
get their companies to implement around
how to how to manage distributed work
and distributed team stuff what best
practices would would you put forth uh
for the world if you're gonna write a
book home book best practices what are
you gonna write yeah well that's a
really interesting topic because I will
identify a few things that I think are
best practices but before I do that I
actually think that the wave that we
typically think about best practices is
really problematic in this context and
I've seen it happen frequently that
organizations identify a best practice
what you owe such as oh how decisions
get made in the organization who has the
authority to make particular decisions
and those practices almost by definition
are developed within a particular
cultural context right hopefully
meaningful they're culturally meaningful
so if you take that quote-unquote best
practice and you you know import it or
export it yeah you get a worse practice
right so maybe now a common practice
sort of but it's not necessarily a best
practice for the context that it's been
those two right and you know we see that
you know as mentioned that the
Innovation Center is you know we
definitely see that where
they the best practice is exported with
the intent of really heightening
innovation but either the practice just
has no meaning in that context sometimes
what will happen is they'll actually do
the process they'll really you know do
something of a ritual engagement
completely ritual engagement yeah you
know we've seen that happen with post-it
notes it's like well everything has to
be written on post-it notes so people
will write everything on post-it notes
but it has no effect whatsoever on
innovation because the meanings don't
translate and then we've also seen cases
where you know where they sort of
changed the meaning or recontextualize
the meaning of it such as and then it
kind of looks different in that context
an example is the use of open space so
you know there's this or a strong belief
now coming out of the US but open space
you know increases collaboration and you
know these serendipitous encounters and
so forth and what we saw in India was
that the open spaces were vacant just
empty nobody would sit in them but they
sat in these project rooms instead so
they weren't sitting in a cubicle
environment as they had been before but
they reinterpreted this notion of you
know working in an environment where
they could see one another and hear one
another but it was just more contained
and that worked beautifully for them and
they were able to be much more
innovative because they had the
flexibility to reinterpret the the
practice and the meaning within their
cultural context anything is a flack for
doing that now they didn't in that case
okay so what what should I be asking you
I mean what what what look kind of if
you hadn't like summarized in one or two
points the key things you think you've
learned
right what would they be a few of them
with touched on Gretchen already but you
know one is that where I have seen the
most problems with organizations is when
the primary motivator for doing
distributed global or global work is
cost well and then what I see is
ironically that it ends up being more
costly because they don't think
strategically for example about how to
divide the work and who should actually
be co-located with whom it ends up just
being you know we need one more body
let's put that body in India instead of
in the Silicon Valley so that's one
really crucial thing is you know as
organizations are becoming more
sophisticated they are thinking much
more strategically about how to
distribute the work rather than just you
know sending it overseas so that's
really crucial and as I see
organizations just moving into this
they are earlier on that learning curve
yep so you know it'd be nice if they
didn't have to make those same mistakes
the other thing which we have talked
about quite a bit is the value of the
site visits as I said the quality of the
collaborations for these really
interdependent long-term teams it just
dramatically changes after there's an
opportunity to meet one another and one
of the things that people you know often
ask here is you know well you know it
gets really expensive people around the
world and it is you know if you're gonna
fly whole team's here and they're
expensive its time-consuming and
exhausting for people because of you
know jet lag and so forth it's bad for
the environment because the carbon
footprint but I think you can be really
strategic about how you do that I don't
think everybody has to travel I believe
that team members have to travel so two
principles one is team members have to
travel on occasions so that they have
insight into that other location
and people need to travel both
directions meaning that not all the
travel goes to headquarters people from
headquarters also really need to
understand what's happening in those
other offices and sometimes we do see
that all the travel comes to
headquarters and then people that
headquarters just don't have a clue
about what the cultural context or is in
those other environments and then with
language yeah language is a really
interesting one because she can't just
fix it it's not like you send everybody
to a week of training and now they're
all native speakers right and I think
that the what we've seen is that the key
is to have conversations about it so
that people are aware of particularly
what it means for the non-native English
speakers because oftentimes the native
English speakers don't have any clue
about how hard it really is for people
who appear to be fluent in English but
are not native so just building that
awareness and that appreciation can make
a big difference and in in the
attributions that people make about
these language switches for example so
all the things I bet you must have
encountered right are differences and
how people from different countries and
different cultures think about Authority
mm-hmm I wonder if you could speak a
little bit about that yeah I mean there
there are definitely differences you
know even going back to some of somebody
named Hofstede did some really early
work identifying power distance as an
important dimension of cultural
differences where in some cultures there
is much more of a an egalitarian view a
sense that decision-making should be
should take place lower levels in the
organization with the people who are
doing the work and in more hierarchical
cultures the decisions tend to be well
hierarchical right it's the people who
are holding higher positions they get to
make the decisions so so that's
absolutely their one of the things we
found interesting though is that in some
places the the younger generation in
some of these cultures that are
traditionally hierarchical really
resonate with a less hierarchical
perspective and this kind of gets at
this cultural content when you get an
age difference - you definitely get an
age difference but what they tell us so
for example you know talking with people
in India you know they'll say wow you
know we actually really think that you
know people at our level should be
making the decisions we have you know
more expertise we're closer to the work
we're in a better position to make these
decisions but then they say but it would
never work here because that's just not
how things are done the people you know
that the managers above us have earned
the position to actually make these
decisions and they're not going to give
that up easily so changing these these
social systems within that's exactly
right well I want to take you back to
some of your early work okay
which I found incredibly surprising
right and if I what struck me was about
your early work was when I'm on a team I
assume that everybody on the team knows
everyone else on the twos on the team
right right and your early work shows
that that's not true what can you blame
to the audience what you failed
yeah I actually so what we found was
that when we asked people who else was
on their team and in some ways it's kind
of funny because this was not something
that we were looking for it was a
methodological glitch in some sense
because you would try to just collect
data right and we you know collected it
by you know just verifying with
everybody's that you know these are all
the
the teens and nobody agreed that who was
on the team which was shocking because
that had never shown up in previous
research in part because people ask the
question differently but it turns out
you know that that work was done
probably close to 20 years ago years ago
and it it turns out that I think we were
detecting a very early trend and now
what we see in organizations is that
teams are much more fluid much less
bounded the membership is moving many
people are on multiple teams at the same
time and it's really based on projects
right and people bringing their
expertise to projects at the time that
it's needed rather than being on
dedicated teams the way it was say 25
years ago so people are flowing in and
out yeah yeah that's kind of hard to
keep track of that right right that's
probably hard to keep track of even if
you're in this one place absolutely yeah
yeah absolutely so what has been um one
of the kinds of questions that people
have that that people in organizations
ask you when they learn you know you
know a lot about distributed work what
do you hear them talking about what I
hear them complaining about one of the
things that that we hear is a lot of
complaints about travel yeah it travels
really expensive and companies would
like to be able to eliminate those costs
it's not the blossom that will eliminate
the cost of that the people who travel
and will eliminate the travel yeah you
know it's mostly the bosses don't want
to eliminate it what I get from people
so the employees are great man I get to
go to China right
I get the gun a hug huh what qualified
no you don't there's that much
enthusiasm about it because it's you
know really time consuming they have to
be away from their families and their
jet-lagged and so forth traveling you
know it's it's perhaps
as sexy as it used to be because there's
so much of it required but I think at
the the people who are actually directly
managing this work recognize that the
travel is really important so they're
really advocating for the travel budget
and other parts of the organization who
are not as directly involved you know
art is convinced of the the critical the
listo conflict within the organization
about how they're going to do this yeah
yeah and a lot of time spent trying to
convince people to allocate the travel
budget but there's also I mean part of
it too comes from people who say you
know I'm jet-lagged
all the time and this is particularly
leaders and organizations you know I'm
traveling you know a couple weeks out of
every month in different continents I'm
jet-lagged all the time because I'm
either coming or going
I'm spending my life on airplanes I
don't see my family anymore consultant
well no actually it's also leaders of
within global organizations I met that
was the problem
oh right that lifestyle sounds like a
consultants life though right right so
many people yeah used to be it was only
consultant or doing so what you know I
hear people complain about Telecom right
having the Cross Buns teleconferences
right yeah it's quite interesting
because the data show that working in
this way extends the workday for many
people many people have to get up at
five o'clock in the morning in order to
have a teleconference or stay up until
nine o'clock ten o'clock it's nice to
have a teleconference what I have to say
about that is this just modern this done
you know the modern way of working that
you know all the labor laws we passed in
the early 20th century about the
eight-hour day
40-hour week is something that we're
really we're ready to give up Oh what is
this honestly I think in the u.s. it's
probably gone by the wayside for
professional workers I think what I see
is the expectation is that they're just
needing to work longer in theory it's
more flexible yeah
but the reality is you add up the hours
people are just working longer one of
the things that that we found in some of
our research though is that that
perception of flex flexibility is key to
the extent that people get to choose how
to extend their day or it seems to
alleviate a lot of the tensions the
conflicts with family and so forth so
they can manage it so this would be more
like I've got to get up at five o'clock
have a meeting they'll expect to see me
in till 11:00 yeah yeah how many firms
are open to that
oh gosh hard to say I mean I'd say most
of those that work yeah and it's
recognized as you know just a reality of
how these things have to function if you
have to get up at 5:00 a.m.
chances are you going to take that call
from home right and then there's some
period of time that you're in the
meeting and then you have to get ready
and then you have to get to work and so
first oh I think there is generally more
flexibility for professional workers to
be able to make it work within within
their families
so I have run out of questions to ask
right so why don't we turn it back over
to our colleagues from SCPD and what
will then do is look at the questions
that have been coming in as we've talked
and see which ones we're gonna be
responding to okay all right yeah we
have some grant really interesting
questions here I'm going to start with
the follower the first one with the
second one we have one we're showing
them up on the board for those of you
can't see this and that's all you except
from Pam and I oh the one of our one of
our viewers right and our listeners
writes in and says the word know is
taboo in some cultures sounds like he
knew my mom Oh some teams will not say
no even though they know it cannot be
done when teams are remote what can be
done to get the real data Oh
knowing that they can't give you bad
news yeah that's a great question a lot
of teams struggle with this I think
they're a couple different ways to get
at that one one of those you know I'm
going back to Steve's question about
best practices one of the best practices
that I have seen in global teams is to
have a cultural liaison so to have
somebody who understands both cultures
and can help with those kinds of
communications and interpreting whether
or not yes actually really means yes in
this particular situation given the you
know the gestures and the facial
expressions of the tone and all of that
so you know part of it can be dealt with
by having somebody who can be in a sense
an interpreter but the other thing that
can be done is you know just avoid the
putting a person in the situation where
they have to say you know have to say no
right so you can do that by for example
asking them to
you know put down a plan for how they're
going to get from A to Z and talking
through the details of that rather than
focusing on will you be done with this
by next to the idea is that by working
on the plan the fact that they say no
comes out and conversation without ever
having to say no exactly it's really
more how can we you know get this done
and what that's what's that gonna look
like as opposed to can you get this done
by the other partners to pay attention
to all the other signals that you're
getting besides what they say is
verbally like when I say sure mom
right right that's enough yeah all right
exactly all right all right so another
another viewer wants to know what kinds
of technologies are most popular for
getting people together on these teams
phone email web mail when web enabled
technologies one of most popular what
what are people using most yeah yeah
that's a good question you know most of
teams that I work with are using
everything in all of the above I would
say that that phone is probably you know
phone conferences are one thing but but
actual one-to-one phone calls are
probably the least common yeah in part
because they don't really support the
language differences accidents native
and non-native English speaking well and
it can make some people who are
non-native English speakers to be less
able to express themselves email is you
know just pervasive we see more and more
instant messaging kinds of you know
instant messaging texting you know some
cell phone definitely a lot of use of
technologies like WebEx we also do see
some video conferencing you know there's
a lot of desktop as well as room based
these numbers name
which is really very effective
particularly the telepresence types of
systems where you can really see the
facial expressions and get more more of
the information that helps you
understand what means that the other
technologies that I'm keeping my eye on
is telepresence robots which for me are
really exciting because they address
more than any of these other so almost
all these technologies are sort of
one-to-one communication or their
meeting oriented virtually everything is
focused on meetings but we know that a
huge percentage of the work that gets
done in most teams does not happen in
meetings it happens outside ratings and
the nice thing about telepresence robots
is that they can actually move around
the space so the way it works is that
you know let's say that I'm working with
a group in I don't know Malaysia and you
know I don't want to keep travelling
there so I have a telepresence robot
that I can log into and then I can
actually move around that space I can go
visit people in their offices or
cubicles I can control what I look at so
it gives me a much better sense of
what's happening in that environment and
I have a lot more freedom to actually
participate in the actual work freaky
yeah there's actually there Business
Studies are some really interesting
things about telepresence robots like
you know people will just turn them off
yeah I want them moving around the
office so they want don't want them you
know spying on them they just turn them
off and it can be a little weird
particularly if you don't know who's
inhabiting that that particular robot
that's roaming the halls but I still
think there's real potential in
technology because it gives you the
context though so so you're rooting for
a Georgia Jets in the world
oh yeah all right well that actually
leads to one of the next questions we
got which is that
ridings a lot harder than speaking for
many people who particularly who are
writing the language that it's not their
own right um they can to speak they can
communicate orally much better than they
can communicate writing and yet email as
you've said email and texting and this
sort of stuff right uh is a primary
medium by which people communicate with
each other how do you you have any ideas
about how you go about this person ask
bridging that gap when you have to work
with non-native English speakers where
the media is primarily written yeah I
mean that is a challenge what are things
that I think it's interesting is we
actually find it goes both ways there
are some people who are just much better
at speaking than writing and then some
people who are actually much better
writing than speaking
you know we've got both issues out there
but in terms of how you bridge the gap
when people are not particularly good at
writing if it's really an issue of
simply communicating with other team
members as opposed to providing customer
materials or something in some sense
it's a better issue than if they're
having trouble speaking right because
what about well because people can take
time now you can actually spend time
crafting an email or you know or a
message in response you can get other
people to look at it and we saw that a
lot in our field studies where you know
somebody would craft an email and then
they would have two other people come
and look at it and make sure that you
know it said what they meant it to say
and there was nothing inadvertently
offensive in it and that it was complete
and so forth so you can actually get
other eyes on it one answer is use
editors try to promote the use of
editors yeah yeah and you know allow
people more time because you know they
can probably get it out given enough
time so can you compare the value of
this is another question coming from you
know this can you compare the
valuing videoconferencing against ya
can the same thing being gained from
both yeah
that's a great question I've thought
about that a lot because I'd like to see
us cut down on the amount of travel I
get a problem for a whole variety of
reasons I think that videoconferencing
can really help with especially really
high end video conferencing can help a
lot with providing that feeling of
having that face to face you know you
can get a better sense of the person and
you know what their sense of humor is
and how they speak and communication
styles and all of that but what you
can't get with current video
conferencing technology is much about
how they function within their cultural
context right and you don't know how
they work outside of the meeting um and
you don't know necessarily what
knowledge they're invoking and you don't
know what their family situation is and
there's just it's it's not the issue is
not the video conferencing it's that
it's supporting a meeting
yeah iron right and until you get
outside of the meeting context you don't
get that same value are you really
saying that if you really want to know
who these people are you got to figure
you you've got to not think about it in
terms of having meetings okay you guys
think about it it seems people in their
content how they live their day-to-day
lives what kind of technologies they
really have as opposed to the
technologies you think they have which I
remember was uh or something that you
discovered it with Katherine Crampton
once discovered in one in one group
where what the Americans just assumed
that all guys in India had all the same
machines that they had which of course
was not true oh so you really need to
see the environment at the larger
environment and how people live in that
environment in order to really
understand who you're interacting and
help people are interact and are treated
by other people within that social
context that matters as well okay so
another
one of our viewers asks about planning
in preparation for these interactions
with team members oh and the importance
of having a well-developed and
established methodology that will be
respected and globally fulfilled right
yep yeah how would you respond to that
well if you know me I'm a planner
planning you know I think that it's a
really good question because you it is
crucial and probably more crucial that
really good planning be done so that
everybody is on the same page everybody
knows what the expectations are
everybody knows who's supposed to be
doing what because that can get really
muddled when people are not in the same
context where where I worry a little bit
is you know about you know defining it
and making sure that everybody is
following the same methodologies
globally right I just think it's really
important to check to make sure that
that methodology which is in fact a best
practice best practice of sorts
works well for all of the people in the
various locations that are needing to
use it and what I do see sometimes is
that just like with other practices we
see the methodology as you know solving
all of these cultural problems but they
actually can create new ones
because they don't fit with they're
being put in allows an anthropologist my
answer would be
you better be you better be aware of the
fact that every practice is culturally
relative right and that when you come if
you're an American you come up with the
best practice right and it might be the
best practice for Americans they might
tolerate it right but it's possible that
others are going to misinterpret it or
not tolerate it or not understand that
and so on and so forth oh yeah
have it not work well I think we're just
about out of time here
thank you for listening and let me turn
it back over to my colleagues here for
the wrap thank you Steve
Thank You Steven Thank You Pam
actually that concludes our webinar
today we hope you'll find the topic
interesting thank you for joining us
bye now